the last time we talked about the lmb we
were discussing about the hypothetical
scenario of how things would play out
if they were to come up against the true
sons on the battlefield
while the vast majority of you agreed
that there really was no contest and
that their training
tactics weapons and equipment were far
superior what if we were to put them up
against another foe
from a similar background in this video
we'll be talking about the possible
outcome
if the last man battalion back in their
heyday when they were at the most
powerful went head to head
with the black tusk
the last man battalion or alien b is a
private military company founded by
charles bliss a highly decorated former
officer of the united states army's
special forces
composed almost entirely of former
commandos from the army's elite 75th
ranger regiment and the cia's
much-feared special operations group
the lmb employs some of the most highly
trained and lethal mercenary soldiers in
the world before the green poison hit
the streets of new york the lmb was
deployed in classified locations across
the western side of asia
and north africa but after the outbreak
a number of wall street businesses came
together to hire them to protect their
servers in physical assets
which were stored deep inside the lower
manhattan quarantine zone
as panic in the financial district began
to spiral out of control
bliss began to clash with local
authorities in his eyes
their actions or lack of had no place in
a war zone
eventually the quarantine in the centre
of manhattan was established
and when the jtf were pulled back the
lmb found themselves abandoned
after a number of days being cut off and
subjected to the brutal aftermath of a
city that was left to fend for itself
bliss decided that the only course of
action was to retake new york city
himself
and establish a new martial order bliss
not only disobeyed a direct order
he executed the jtf officer in charge
the lmb are convinced that not only the
city but the entire nation would
collapse
under the chaos that is unfolding during
the pandemic but it is them who would
help america come out of this
and see the other side their objective
is to gain full control of new york
and then use their newly created
city-state as a base to create a new
world order
one where only those with strength of
will and character
survive
black tusk is a large private military
company
although their origins for the most part
have been deliberately redacted from
official records
reports show that they're composed of
both military and paramilitary units
with a long history of working for
undisclosed elements of the united
states government
the black tusk operatives have been
active in everything from covet regime
change operations
to on-the-ground counter-insurgency
efforts in latin america
the middle east southeast asia and north
africa
in the hours following the outbreak in
new york city before the full extent of
the crisis was even known
the black tusk units and equipment was
starting to be shipped back to the
united states
which leads to the question of their
involvement but this goes much deeper
than the pmc
the people who are responsible for
employing the black tusk are still
unknown
but what is apparent at this stage is
that they are attempting to use this
chaotic time to take control of the
country
division reports show that the black
tusk have already secured key strategic
locations around the us
including military bases power grid and
general utility infrastructure
communication hubs financial
institutions
and high-tech corporate campuses in more
recent times
they've been called into washington dc
to neutralize federal resistance
counter the division activation and take
control of the capital
while still a pmc who has been employed
to carry out someone else's agenda
a large portion of their leadership
believes in the vision of those who are
calling the shots
the idea of abolishing the current way
of doing things and establishing a new
world order
only further fuels their drive to keep
on track as they believe what they're
doing is needed to have the united
states come out on top
this belief gives the black tusk the
unwavered ability to remove any threats
that may hinder this future development
of the country whether it be u.s
soldiers
national security operatives like the
division and civilians
both the black tusk and the lmb have
quite a number of roles within their
ranks
from the assault rushers throwers and
snipers all the way through to the
support
engineers and heavies these two factions
are structured in a very similar way
with only very minor differences between
the classes
the only real difference being due to a
mutual agreement with aaron kina
a number of former division agents
turned rogue have joined the lmb forces
as squad leaders or commanding officers
l b rifleman make up the bulk of their
forces they use assault rifles and
flashbang or stun grenades
they are very well trained and should be
watched at all times
as they are constantly trying to flank
enemies while they're distracted
the l b snipers are powerful and
accurate any threats caught out in the
open
will quickly be downed yet staying in
cover isn't the answer either
the l b scouts are fast and will rush
straight towards the enemy with their
semi-automatic shotguns
and if they fail there are the
grenadiers with grenade launchers
and heavy gunners laying down
suppressive fire from medium range
on top of this they have medics with
powerful healing stations
which will quickly undo any progress
made by the opposing force if left
unchecked
then there are the first wave rogue
agents who are deadly at all range
and utilize a number of shdtech to
further tip the battle in the lmb's
favor
much like the lmb the bulk of the black
tusk soldiers are made up of the assault
class
these units are well trained and highly
proficient in the use of cover to cover
movement
soldiers will do their best to split up
and surround their foes
forcing them to back up into a corner
once locked down
the throwers step in using airburst
grenade launchers
they are able to deal massive damage to
targets behind cover or disorientate
bring them back out into the open but
they also have drone operators
who utilize aerial-based demolition
drones to laser onto targets and flush
them out of cover
black tusk snipers are skilled at range
but are more than capable if enemies get
too close
while utilizing cover they will swiftly
move around the outside of the conflict
area setting up decoy lenses to confuse
enemies around their position
buying them extra time to scope in on
their targets
on top of this they will deploy drones
that will seek out enemies and stun them
granting them an even greater window of
opportunity for a clear shot
the black tusk also have an answer for
foes who have a greater arsenal of
firepower
the controller class is responsible for
the unmanned ground vehicles
like the heavily armored and
well-equipped mini tanks
if outnumbered the tank class is well
suited to the role of halting enemy
advances
by laying down suppressive fire from
their chain fed minigun while absorbing
a considerable amount of damage
however heavy use of equipment and
drones against the black dusk isn't
necessarily the answer either
the medic class isn't just skilled in
keeping their allies alive but is also
equipped with emp jammers
able to disable any machinery on the
battlefield
unlike the majority of the other
factions the lmb and the black tusk
existed before the outbreak they are
both pmcs with vast experience in
overseas conflict zones
with members having been recruited after
serving in the u.s armed forces
the last man battalion is built up
almost entirely of former commandos from
the army's elite 75th ranger regiment
and the cia's special operations group
the black tusk have hand-picked their
soldiers from militaries other pmcs
and academies throughout america their
troops have been chosen for their skills
in highly specialized areas
including reconnaissance and
surveillance to technology equipment
and weapon experts
although not always the case with
private military companies the last man
battalion have spared no expense in
equipping their troops with the latest
and greatest when it comes to weapons
and military gear
they are far more heavily armed than
even the most well-funded military corps
and this is only further supported by
the rogue division agents who provide
field support
in the advanced shd tech and weaponry
when it comes to equipment
technology and weaponry the l b are
vastly superior to what almost all other
factions have at their disposal
but then we have the black tusk with
seemingly limitless financial backing
their equipment isn't just state of the
art it's practically unattainable to the
bulk of their foes
their weaponry combat gear and
technology is next level
they have a wide range of drone
technology emps
mines support stations and mini tanks
experimental tech like warhounds
marauder drones
and the razorback weapons deployment
platform
the last man battalion is a private
military company consisting of soldiers
who are highly trained former united
states special forces
after the dollar flu struck new york the
lmb were brought back into the country
to assist the wealthy
they have returned from conflict zones
overseas and they aren't particularly
happy with being thrown into the centre
of where the epidemic first started
compared to other factions in the
manhattan quarantine zones the lmb
have far more combat specialists with
top grade military gear and weapons
and their defensive positions were more
heavily fortified
after they were then abandoned by the
jtf they took it upon themselves to
correct the horrible job that the
government was doing
using their own form of strict martial
law they are prepared to use all means
necessary to ensure that the city
and then the country survives these
events
then there is the black tusk also a
private military company but they
weren't working on their own
the black tusk was hired by an unknown
organization to pave the way for a new
dynasty
and are supported by cutting-edge field
technologies and military-grade spec ops
vehicles
that can deploy troops rapidly anywhere
they have a very specific set of goals
eliminate all hostile factions and
groups in washington dc
suppress civil unrest disarm and control
the settlements
and to neutralize the strategic homeland
division and any armed forces allied to
it
but unlike other factions in both new
york city and washington dc
who share a similar goal the black tusks
have an extremely high level of backing
from their employer
but not just from a financial aspect
they are also able to provide unusually
precise intel
on everything and everyone around them
while the lmb and black tusk are similar
in a number of ways with the bulk of
their soldiers being made up of former
military and special forces
plus the fact they both have vast
experience in overseas conflict zones
and obviously they're both pmcs if this
is all we had to go on
this fight would be fairly even however
if we start at the most basic level
the black task already starts to pull
ahead although we aren't given any
specific number
the sheer size of these groups seems to
be considerably different
the l b isn't a small force by any means
but in comparison to the black tusk
they're only a small blip on the radar
we need to remember that we're only
fighting a small portion of the black
tusk in-game
the black tusk special unit or btsu
other than the stories of multiple
facilities being captured around the
country
we really haven't seen the bulk of their
forces but for the purpose of this
let's just say that the btsu numbers are
the entirety of the black tusk
their training and tactics on the
battlefield are relatively on par
they both utilize cover well and display
strong discipline in even the most
difficult of situations
however this is where the black tusk's
mysterious employer comes in
the seemingly limitless funds they're
able to provide has them coming back
from
every engagement stronger than they were
beforehand even against the shd
after every loss they returned somewhere
else with even greater numbers and more
powerful weapons
an argument could be made in favor of
the lmb with the armored personnel
carrier and the falcons lost incursion
but this really was a one-off and is
certainly not to the same level of what
was seen from the black tusk
it isn't the numbers or even necessarily
the funding that separates the black
tusk
it's their access to technology that is
even greater than what the shd has to
offer
these unknown benefactors aren't just
providing all the money in the world
they have some very obvious ties to the
inner workings of the us government
from our time in the pentagon and the
darpa labs we can see that a number of
the unmanned drones
like the marauder-class quadcopter the
mini tanks and the warhounds
have been developed here but also the
majority of the shd tech
and the black tusk know that this is
their advantage heavily utilizing this
tech everywhere possible
yes the lmb have rogue agents in their
ranks but at that time their abilities
were somewhat nerfed
it wasn't until later on that kina was
able to take full advantage of what they
previously had at their disposal as
division agents
when the rogue agent network was
established but even still the black
tusk has shown their ability to take out
division agents
prior to their attack on the capital i
know a lot of people refer to the white
tusk as being former lmb
therefore they must be better but these
are still black tusk troops for the most
part
it's true that the black tusk absorbed
the lmb into their ranks some time after
their leader was taken out
but they were then completely re-kitted
out with gear and weaponry and added to
existing black tusk units
although i believe this hypothetical
battle to be completely one-sided due to
the technology aspect alone
i still don't think that this is their
strongest attribute
the black tusk leadership has always
been one step ahead
their intel is far beyond anything that
the other factions have at their
disposal
and this includes the shd they're sort
of like keener in that way
volcano not new kenner that goes a
disappointment
whoever these employers are the black
tusks are just their pawns
the inside information on its own makes
them the most powerful faction that
we've come across
in the division universe we've had some
small clues as to who they are with
characters like natalya sokolova
but i believe she's only the tip of the
iceberg as far as finding out their true
identity
potentially just another figurehead
behind something much much bigger
in the research for this video i was
really just left with the feeling of
needing more i think this long period of
having no
new content being added to the story is
starting to affect me
don't get me wrong i'm enjoying going
back and catching up on some of the
stuff i never got around to talking
about
and i'm looking forward to going through
some of the prequel stuff that we'll be
seeing in the heart of fire audiobook
i'm just really holding out for the next
expansion to the story there has just
been so much lift hanging
anyway thank you very much for watching
this and i'll catch in the next one
[Music]
cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
uh